so now we have another occasion where
sean my producer has enlisted me to
endure psychological and emotional abuse
for your amusement
torches
and uh this time we are descending into
the caverns of tick tock again
to explore the polyamorous community uh
i'm not a covid germaphobe by by any
means but this is one occasion where you
know a mask and especially gloves rubber
gloves might be required so apparently
on tick tock a whole bunch of people you
know are in open relationships
polyamorous relationships and they've
made videos advertising and uh
explaining and defending their lifestyle
i find it so sad
and pathetic that i don't think i can
watch very many of them but we'll uh
we'll watch maybe two or three of them
just to see just to get a little taste
and we'll start with an easy one let's
look at this one here
[Music]
just mind your business right well
except that your husband's sexual
activity
is your business if you didn't intend to
share in that business with him to in
effect make it your business exclusively
like exclusively your business
exclusively then why did you marry him
in what sense is this even a marriage
for what reason is it a marriage but
then we go down a rabbit hole that
people don't want to go down of course
which is like now we've got to come up
with a definition of marriage
what is it exactly and once you start
doing that
then you're drawing lines and you might
find that we're excluding certain types
of relationships that you would prefer
to include and that's why we don't
define it at all and now we have to call
this a marriage also you know what this
is like it's like going into business as
an accountant and then your first client
sends their tax documents over to you
and you go whoa wait a second this
that's none of my business your
financial information is private keep it
to yourself boundaries dwight come on
well yeah it's private but the
accountant client relationship is
supposed to largely center around
private information that's the whole
point
i might have lost the threat in that
analogy a little bit i don't know where
i was going i think i think i made a
point there i'm pretty sure but let's uh
let's keep watching so my husband
casually dropped today that he met this
chick on bumble that's only in town for
a week so we all know what that means so
i sent him a text like babe live your
best life if this thing goes all night
you want to go back to her airbnb
you want to stay so that you can hit it
in the morning again
live your best life babe i got it here
at home why did i do it because i'm such
a good polyamorous wife first of all um
but also because you put that karma in
the bank and then y'all girls gonna cash
it out later if you want to be good at
polyamory you have to show up for your
partner the way that you want them to
show up for you and if i had somebody
roll into town you better believe i
would want my husband to step it up
so there we go and that that's that's
really it isn't it that's the whole
shebang if you'll pardon the expression
why do you have a
polyamorous relationship what's the
point of an of a quote unquote open
marriage which is a contradiction in
terms it's an oxymoron an open marriage
you know marriages are closed by
definition that's why that's the point
of them but uh why do it well it's
entirely self-serving you know that's
the point this is mutually agreed upon
adultery one adulterous spouse tolerates
the adultery of the other spouse so that
she has a license to behave the same way
it's also emotional blackmail at the
same time or putting karma in the bank
as she puts it again we see how the
marital union has been flipped on its
head gutted emptied hollowed out
rendered pointless
because marriage is supposed to be a
loving and sacrificial uh union between
two people who pledge to serve one
another until death that's what that's
what marriage is i don't know what other
point it could have if it's not that and
letting your spouse sleep around so that
you can also sleep around is not loving
service it's self-service and there's a
difference in fact the difference is
that those two things are opposites a
few decades ago private citizens used to
be largely that private what's changed
well the internet think about everything
you browse searched for watched or
tweeted now imagine all of that data
being crawled through collected and
aggregated by third parties into a
permanent public record your record
having your private life exposed for
others to see was once something only
celebrities worried about
but an era where everybody is online
everyone is a public figure we're all
kind of celebrities in our own right to
keep my data private then i go online i
turn to expressvpn
every time i turn the expressvpn on i'm
given a random ip address shared by
other expressvpn customers that makes it
more difficult for third parties to
identify me and harvest my data the best
part is how easy expressvpn is to use no
matter what device you're on whether
it's a phone laptop smart tv whatever it
is all you have to do is tap one button
to get protected it really is that
simple so if like me you believe that
your data is your business secure
yourself with the number one rated vpn
on the market visit expressvpn.com wall
should get three extra months for free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s
vpn dot com slash welsh go to
expressvpn.comwalsh to learn more i
think i can tolerate maybe just one more
of these once
dear friends
we haven't heard yet from a polyamorous
man so we've heard from the women let's
hear from a man i use that term loosely
of course hey man i think you should
know that i saw your wife with another
man
did they have leftovers
what
did they have
a bag
of food
yes
who
was holding
the bag
she
was
yeah
i have to say i take great exception to
the fact this is a bearded man to see a
bearded man cuckolding himself like this
is extremely discouraging to me uh it
brings shame on the whole community of
beardsmen
of course the cuckold effect um kind of
he affects this ironic
detached pose unconcerned that his wife
is being sexually satisfied by another
man
you get back here you make love to my
wife all he cares about is the leftovers
ha ha get it
he's not he's not a lame jealous cuckold
he's a cool sarcastic one that makes it
all better
so they're really two options here i
think
one when we talk about this guy and and
trying to interpret and understand
what's going on
one is that is that uh you know your
wife is out with another man
and you're pretending not to be bothered
by it but really inside you're dying and
you're eating yourself alive you're
drowning in resentment and jealousy and
you hate your life
[Music]
can we talk about this uh not in front
of everyone
but you're trying to convince the world
but really yourself that you're totally
fine with it
so that that's possible
or two
you've been so neutered so thoroughly uh
defanged and de-bald
that you actually don't feel anything
anymore when your wife openly cheats on
you cena's your husband it's it's oh no
he knows
you're a lucky dog i'm not sure which is
worse
they're both pathetic beyond words
what i do know though is that i can't
watch any more of these videos so that's
it